Millennials have a tough road piles of
student debt high rents stagnant wages
and now McKinsey the big famous
consulting firm is down on Millennials
retirement fortunes well take heart
Millennials if you save for retirement
invest your money regularly and here's
the key take a global approach to
investing your future will be much
brighter than Mackenzie thinks
Mackenzie recently warned Millennials
that they'll have to work seven years
longer than their parents or save twice
as much as mom and dad to enjoy similar
retirements why because investments in
US and Western European stocks and bonds
are not going to grow much how low
growth are we talking McKinsey predicts
that US stocks will grow at about half
the rate they did during the last 30
years and u.s. bonds they won't grow at
all okay that may be true but there's
another difference between Millennials
and their parents Millennials have more
options when their parents were their
age they could only invest in the US and
Western European countries but markets
are more developed today and Millennials
have virtually the whole world available
to them that's a big deal not only
because Millennials can spread their
eggs across more baskets but also
because the investing world outside the
US and Western Europe looks much more
promising if you're looking for strong
growth over time the yield on US
aggregate bonds is just 2.1 percent
meanwhile emerging market bonds are
yielding 5.4 percent stocks tell a
similar story emerging market stocks are
yielding nine point four percent more
than double what they are in the US
remember though that even in the US
markets and the returns they provide
constantly evolved back in 2007 US
stocks were yielding just three point
eight percent fast-forward through the
financial crisis and by early 2009 the
yield had almost doubled to seven and a
half percent
so Millennials don't be disappointed
that you aren't in the same investing
universe as your parents instead count
yourself lucky the whole world awaits
you